I think we'll do another video on why economists,
mainstream economists have missed this so much
because it breaks my heart the pathetic idiocywe
see from economists so much um but the truth is
they're rich, they're from rich families, they're
from rich backgrounds, they're getting paid right
they don't give a **** right...
okay so this is going to be the final video in
the series about the 700 billion it's going to
cover how it ended up with the rich and how that
affects the economy, okay so we've been doing a lot
of videos on this 700 billion recently I think
it's a really useful way to criticise the
government and also to understand what's happened
in the economy uh the last video we did explains
exactly what the 700 billion was; it's the total
government deficit since the beginning of covid
which is the total amount of money essentially the
government has given out above and beyond taxes so
when the government taxes it moves around but when
it gives extra out that creates more money in society
and someone ends up with more money um 700
billion pounds massive massive amount of money
£14,000 for everyone... every single adult
in the country um it was always going to have
massive economic effects, now a big part of the
argument of of this channel is that that money
has largely ended up with the richest um in fact
the reason why we made this channel is because
right at the beginning of covid it was pretty
clear to me that 250 billion pounds which is
how much it was then was going to end up with
the rich people in the country it was going to
transform inequality it was going to have massive
implications for ordinary people so that's why we
made this channel and we made the very first
video on this channel so the very first video
on this channel basically explains exactly
that how that money ended up with the richest
um I'm not going to go through a completely
detailed explanation if you want that then
go and watch that video we'll put a link in
the description we'll put a little pop-up
maybe for it so you can see that video but
I'm going to describe very very succinctly
how that money ended up with the richest people
in society so since we know that £700 billion
was given out we must also know that somebody has
it because it's so much (£14,000 per adult)
it raises quite a big question as to who because I
suspect that the vast majority of people watching
will not have accumulated £14,000 cash in
the last few years in fact most people will find
themselves poorer now than they were 3years ago
um so it's a big question right who has themoney
and it was a question that waspuzzling me
at the beginning of Covid-19 because
at the beginning of Covid I think the narrative
was this money is going to furloughed workers
but if you look at furloughed workers they
didn't get richer right so we... 250 billion
which is what it was then that's £5,000 per
adult in the country you know forevery
furloughed worker it's something like £50,000
right because not everybody was furloughed
or maybe something like £40,000, you know
of courseevery furloughed worker is not
accumulating £40,000 remember the question
here is not'who gets the money initially?' its
'who ends up accumulating the money?' you know
we'repouring 250 billion, we're pouring 700 billion in
it's going to swim around and it's going to end up
with some people who ends up with that 700 billion?
right and it was a bit of a mystery to me at the
beginning of Covid right because the narrative
was all 'it's the furloughed workers' but the
furloughed workers weren't accumulating anything
in fact they're getting poorer because they're
getting less (80%) so it it raises the question of
'who actually ends up with the money?' & all you need
to do is follow the money through the system right
so furloughed workers they get extra money from
the government but they don't get richer because
they don't get their wages anymore, okay so
who's got the wages? well it's companies that pay
the wages so but are company's getting richer? well
actually the companies who furloughed their workers
during Covid generally got poorer during Covid
because they were shut down they weren't getting
their income okay so who gets the income that
normally goes to companies that then gets paid
to the workers well that's customers and actually
this is where the money accumulates because
customers massively cut their spending during
Covid but crucially not all customers right if you're
an ordinary family or especially if you'rea poor
family almost all of your expenses isessentials;
rent, mortgage, food, bills... thesepayments did not
decrease during Covid, but if you're, well what payments
did decrease during Covid? theanswer is non-essential
or luxurypayments; holidays, bars, restaurants...
all of the things that were shut down basically
theater this kind of thing and who has the highest
spending on those luxuries? it's basically
a perfect proxy for how rich you are so
what happened during Covid & during lockdown
was that the spending specifically of the rich
collapsed, poor people spending barely fell
at all but the spending of the rich collapsed
which meant that anybody who worked in the luxury
non-essential sector lost their incomes and the
government stood in to fill the gap so essentially
systemically what happened during Covid was
an expenditure of the rich got replaced
by an expenditure of the government
which meant that the government
printed largely and pumped money in
that went to ordinary workers they use that to
pay their bills, their rent, their mortgage; that
goes to that the owners of the assets who are the
rich and the rich simply it was basically illegal
for them to spend that money so what it meant was
that the rich accumulated that money and this was
so systemically obvious at the beginning
of Covid and so unbelievably unbelievably
little analysed I think it was I think it's I
think it's the most fantastic indictment of the
state of Economics today that in the last
three years the government of this country
has given out seven billion and I looked at the
U.S number and I think it was 3 trillion right
that governments can give out trillions of
pounds and nobody even asked the question
of 'who is going to accumulate that money?' it's
it's and you know we'll probably do a video on
this at some point but what that comes down to
is there is a there is a terrible woeful lack
of analysis of distribution in economics so
that no one even asks the question basically
um but you know the government gave out
£14,000per adult somebody had to have it
if you do the analysis which I've just gone
through it's quite obvious that that money
will end up with the richest because that money
has gone in it's basically as a subsidy for the
collapsed spending of the rich so so it was it
was unbelievably obvious at the beginning of
covid that what we would see is the biggest and
fastest increase in inequality in the history
of the country and if you have an unbelievably
rapid increase in inequality during a period of
time when the economy is literally closed it is
really obvious that on reopen what you'll see
is a massive increase in quality of life of therich
& a massive decrease in quality of life inthe poor
what else could you possibly expectif you've
increased inequality enormously ina period
when the economy was closed & the...
Idon't know if you remember but the reporting
the media reporting during covid was just about the
stupidest thing you have ever heard right they
were like everybody's accumulating so much money
we're going to have a Roaring Twenties you know
you don't create Roaring Twenties just by
giving money out right if you give if you
give a huge amount of money specifically to the
rich what you create is a cost of living crisis
and this brings us to the next point of the videookay
so we're concluding now how the money ended up
with the richest hopefully it's clear if anybody
wants to understand more go back and watch
the very first video on this channel we'll put
a link in the description it's called 'how the
rich got richer from Covid-19' but the next question
Ithink this is a really interesting discussion is
how does it affect you and how does it affect
the economy so there's lots and lots of ways
in which wealth inequality can increase in society
the most obvious way is that ordinary families
lose their assets and those assets start to be
owned by richer families the directtransfer
of assets from the middle class to therich
that's happening you know you can see that
that tends to happen generationally so what you
seeis middle class families; the older generation
own property the younger generation cannot afford its
own property those properties end up being owned
by the younger generations of richer families so
generationally assets are being transferred from
middle class to the rich that's one way inequality
can increase another way wealth inequality can
increase is is debt a big increase in debt from
the middle class to the rich and we're seeing
that as well in the massive increase in size
of mortgages and also matter increasing size
of government debt okay that's another way that
inequality can increase I think both of those if
you do them slowly enough people don't recognise
right like generationally the older generation
doesn't realise their kids are losing property
younger people are kind of realising I think
um the increase in debt it happens slowly people
don't really really notice it that much but people
don't like it people don't like having a lot of
debt and people don't like losing their assets
but what happened during Covid was a massive
increase in inequality without taking your assets
and without putting you into
debt and what that was was just
printing a crap ton of money and giving it to the
rich does that hurt you? and how does it hurt you?
you know I think it's really worth just sitting
and asking yourself the question and you know
people watching you might even want to pause the
video and ask yourself the question what do I
think would happen let's assume that money went to
top 10% so you give the richest 5 million adults in
the country each £140,000 cash, what do you think
would happen? stop for a minute and think what
would happen if the government gave the richest
5million adults in the country each £140,000 cash
well the first thing is they're going to buy
assets so you're going to see assets go up
because rich people tend to prefer to buy assets
but they already own assets right so that they're
just buying assets from each other there will
be some net transfer of assets from the middle
class the rich so some assets will go up but they
can't buy enough assets because they've been given
so much money so asset prices go up then they feel
even richer and then if then they start increasing
their spending right they start increasing their
spending that pushes up the prices of everything
you know one of the big reasons why food became
more expensive even before the Ukraine war was
because the cost of shipping became more expensive
because the rich were buying so much stuff that it
was filling up the shipping containers you
know ultimately these guys they spend more
money it pushes the price of stuff up and people
sometimes turn them out to me and say oh but you
say the rich have like they prefer to save which
is true it's true the rich prefer to save but they
don't save everything if you give 5 millionpeople
140 Grand each you're going to push thepricesof
stuff up it's such an enormous amountof money
such an enormous amount of money & I think
it's interesting because it's a really
interesting way to make people poorer is
to print money and give it to the rich because
you don't even see it happening right, you know
it happens behind closed doors you know and in
fact what most people think is the government is
really good they gave money to furloughed workers
you know but if you actually ask a question of who
ended up with the money then what you see is a
massive massive transfer of cash to the rich and
what I think is quite interesting if you
were to ask an economist that question
five years ago before Covid, what do you think
would happen if we gave the richest 5 million
adults in the country 140 Grand each
they would all say to you - inflation crisis
they would all say that to you
and yet what happened was we did that
we immediately had an inflation crisis
and everybody says well because of the war in
Ukraine and you know you will remember it was
you know when this channel was, the invasion of
Ukraine was when this channel was much smaller
and I called you up and I was like this is gonnabe
a [__] disaster you know of course the waritself
is a disaster right but looking at itjust purely
from the perspective of Western Economies
the British Economy; I said what thiswill do
is it will take entirely the blame forthe
inflationary crisis they will blame it all
on Ukraine and people don't remember but the
inflationary crisis started before the invasion
of Ukraine right um and it was always inevitably
going to happen in my opinion but as soon as that
all happened I was like this is I cannot tell
you what a disaster this is for our economy and
for the future of our our society and I I don't
at all want to undermine what's happened to the
people of Ukraine that it's of course a disaster
right for I am a British Economist my job is to
analyse the UK economy as soon as that happened
it was a disaster for Western European economies
and the American economy because if that hadn't
have happened we would still have seen a mass
inflationary crisis and it would have beenvery
difficult to blame it on anything other thanthis
massive accumulation of cash of the rich during
Covid but as soon as that war happensyou have
a very easy scapegoat it's becauseof the war
it's because of the war and it means thatwhat's
happened is the biggest ever transfer ofwealth
from the government to the richest peoplein the
world, in the history of the world, followedby
the most obvious consequences you would have
predicted; an increase in inequality and increase
in asset prices, an increase in cost of living,
decreasing quality of life for ordinary people
and no one is even talking about the accumulation
of cash by the rich it is coming in a little bit
you know you know and we try to raise that up the
profile as much as we can but you know I would
really encourage anybody watching this video now
if you haven't seen it go back and watch the first
video on this channel came out in June 2020 right
before the inflation crisis or any of this it was
in the middle of lockdown um and I said what
you'll see is massive increase in inequality, massive
increase in inflation, massive increase in asset
prices and ordinary people will be thrown into
poverty and probably austerity, all of those
things have happened okay and it's you know
the reason I was right then is the same reason
I've been right for ****ing 15 years because I
understand that the distribution is important
to the economy which is something that most
economists miss and you know if you massively
increase inequality when the economy is closed
how can you expect not to cause a decrease
in living standards? where has the increasing
wealth of the rich come from if not from poverty
for the rest? you know if they become richer they
will take a larger share of the resources you
know and and I think we'll do another video on
why economists mainstream economists have missed
this so much because it it breaks my heart the
pathetic idiocy we see from economists so much
um but the truth is they're rich they're from rich
families, they're from rich backgrounds, they're
getting paid they don't give a **** right
um people need to be aware that inequality has
increased massively in the last three years and
that when inequality increases, broad living
standards fall, not only that but it creates a
spiral effect because the end result is ordinary
families will sell their assets to support
themselves which means they get poorer still which
means wealth inequality inequality gets bigger still
you know another video which people shouldwatch
if they're here watching now is the flows ofwealth
video which makes it clear once inequality
gets big it starts to spiral out of control
so the end message here is number
one that money went to the rich
number two if you give the rich a ton of money it
creates inflation and makes ordinary people poorer
number three that creates increased
flows of wealth from the middle class
to the rich which makes the situation
worse still so you know really this
is a dire emergency situation I can't put I
can't put any finer a point of it on that um
um but unfortunately most economists from rich
families from rich backgrounds getting well paid
studied for many years not looking at inequality
at all they will not fix this they will not fixthis
honestly they will not fix this and you
know the reason I made this channel
is because I am very aware
if nothing is done about this
the economy will collapse very
seriously in the coming years so
this is why I go on and on about 700 billion
pounds you know um and it will be 800 and it'll
be 900 and I will keep the viewers informed with
what it is um but something has to be done but
I think using this number is is a great
opportunity I've spoken about the channel
to attack the government and not just in this
country in the U.S I think it's *eight* trillion
I'll put the exact U.S number in the description
because I know we do have some viewers in the U.S
um ask them where the money is now because they
cannot answer that question they cannot ask that
question and if they did answer that question then
it would be unbelievably painfully obvious what we
have to do to fix this crisis if we were to taxback
the rich just enough to make them as rich as
they were 3 years ago we would have enough
togive every single adult in this entire country
£14,000 each and this crisis would
be over um so go at em and you know
write to your MP, call into the radio station, go
on the news, put it on your Facebook, tell your
friends and family, follow us on everything; TikTok,
Instagram, Facebook, Twitter of course YouTube
share these videos um and let's get something
done about it man because if nothing is done
things get worse and worse but we can make change
if we're willing to, to hold these guys to account
rich ****ers
money currently is flowingfrom the
government to the rich leaving the
government with big piles of debt and the
rich with big piles of money there's one other
thing they can do with that mass amount
of income they can buy your mom's house